how you doing okay thanks for coming
thank you you're in this this big meg
Ryan Phil did you hang a big picture
yeah
know what she did ask me to do yoga
constantly she would always call and ask
me to do yoga but I haven't taken her up
on it why not well I'm not really a yoga
sort I don't really like breathing with
other people at the same time like a lot
of breathing rippy right yeah but I do
other things like other health attempts
well at someone's recommendation I went
to this place and it was a week long
fast of all liquids it's a place called
week hair you can find out weak hair
calm take it we care like we care about
you about your health about your fast as
long as we care yeah they take away food
from you for a week as opposed should be
really it's supposed to be like really
am healing or cleaning or cleansing I
don't know what people are into these
days really right right um but so I
wanted I imagine that was gonna be lots
of like smoothies and massages but in
fact it's more like you have lemon water
lemon water tea then you get a soup
that's sort of like The Exorcist pea
soup at the end of the night and a lot
of enemas is what the thing is when it
which I was not aware of the enemas I'm
not like an enema type I wonder is it
who is an enema type apparently there's
plenty of there's this place is crowded
are like you know get me as many enemas
as much as possible you might not think
so but you know what we live in New York
I mean it's a big country right and okay
I was wrong to say that there aren't
people out there who want enemas
constantly I apologize but so I'm on
your side is where you pay to have this
done do you pay you pay you pay for
torture I I don't look like a cult it
sounds like it sounds weird yeah thanks
for telling you now I yeah like three
weeks ago and but really I found myself
like no massages right no smoothies but
like running from the enema specialist
right absolutely like no no it's okay
she's trying to lasso you with the hose
yeah
now did you I'm clean you're not
didn't want to hear that all right
you're not having a great time late
because you had a mishap of some kind
before you came to New York to visit
yeah well no I didn't visit cuz I live
here but I was visiting Los Angeles and
and out in Los Angeles I lost myself in
the last night now I thought would be
really fun to like run by the ocean and
just run by the waves or something like
run in the waves it's LA there's no
concrete you know and and then I guess
my cell phone must have fallen out of my
pocket so I get back to New York I'm
trying to get my cell phone back and I
call up i dial my own number and I have
a lot of spare time and I dial my own
number and and this one picks up and
she's like hola and I said oh so you
have my cell phone I I want my cell
phone back I'm gonna give you a drop-off
point said I know it's a phone you know
and she didn't know what I wanted from
her and then I you guys I dialed the
wrong number I felt really sorry
everybody didn't start screaming at her
you have my phone I kind of I tried to
sort of actually mellow out what I did
say to her I I was a little bit
ferocious with the poor lady so you
don't have your without a cell phone in
New York City which is difficult I guess
but it's also kind of freeing cuz
there's like a certain sense of like
spontaneity you get you can just like
you know get on the subway for no reason
at all you don't know if people are
trying to reach you you have tons of
spare time people don't really keep
mentioning you have a lot of spare time
I hope everything's okay so what what
are you fine I'm an actor no one needs
to reach me it's not that important you
know so I think is a refreshing
viewpoint it's a nice it's a nice
attitude you hang so what do you do
every time in New York well I don't see
like three movies in a row for example
is what I'll do and I don't know if
someone's trying to reach me in the
middle or anything but you know I'll go
see em and then and and I guess you know
I'll go to a Lincoln Center which is
they show a lot of the great silent
movies there which is I really like
silent I really like actually went right
when silence ended and they started with
talkies that period right so I'll go
there and they usually have the usually
double features so at halftime or
whatever they call it in the movie world
okay I think that's what it is half
there's a buzzer that goes off and
everyone yeah
so then um so then so then I I find that
like I mean I'll be in a trenchcoat
smoking a cigarette Julliard is right
there and I like to watch the students
because I know that they're really
talented you know they're all like price
singing and dancing and stuff so when I
put on a trench coat and watch kids I'm
asked to leave that's cool I do it
sometimes in Washington Square Park too
cuz then you can find the NYU students
down there and you just look at and you
just look at students it's a great
school congratulations Wow they were
pro-taliban
too and you connect and and and what are
you you're just looking at students but
you must get recognized I mean you're
you're well known not so much in the
trench coat with the creepy shades you
know creepy shades and the stalking
people I only followed a guy home once
from the theater and the truth is I just
seen in the bed wall the police I only I
saw in the bedroom which is like a
psychological thriller and he was seeing
mahal and drive which was a David Lynch
movie so I figured that maybe you know
you followed a guy you bring a trench
coat and it was only a couple of blocks
and I had seen you know that was my
third movie that day SARS you know
really not in the same place and it's
people are supposed to stalk you and
that's the weird thing
traditionally that's how you're looking
for stalkers yeah okay you don't want to
say that I'd like one too though
actually yeah it's depressing when no
one cares Kate and Leopold yeah if you
stalk me I'll stalk you I'll meet you at
halftime but the next movie
Kate and Leopold you and Meg line opens
next Friday yeah it's a hell of a
picture go see the hella picture kids
come by again though nice talk
[Applause]